[Music]
hey everybody you watch out the record
when we talk about what and today Tim is
gonna talk about his first argument that
he had with gia cuz we want the real
drum okay let me tell you how to drama
this isn't the first argument it's the
most realistic what this is probably
like our most consistent argument in the
beginning anyways because like what's
really bad it's pretty bad yeah it's
very serious yeah okay is this is hard
to talk about she doesn't like the way I
do dishes
okay Oh team gia yeah no okay no Tim
okay look it's all is the whole thing
it's the whole thing and we finally
addressed it on my podcast recently is
it a typhi no I think it's um here's the
thing I cuz I used to work at my
family's restaurant and also you know I
worked at California Pizza Kitchen and
[ __ ] so you're not a clean
professionally so shut the [ __ ] up you
actually get worse at cleaning dishes
all restrooms you realize it does have
to be that clean yep
interesting seems like why you're the
best light for me at least that's what
happened to me it's like when I went out
my mom taught me I was super thorough
and when I started working at a
restaurant lunch rush dinner rush that
makes you half-assed cleaning well what
do you do you just like spray yeah
that's good
I wish I had it did you get the pressure
sprayer oh [ __ ] there's no more
horseback yeah home sometimes right now
I'll turn on the little the jet stream
thing and I was like there's no problems
alright it's cool what no it's really
bad that's what I do with the grill you
know like when you first get a grill you
want to scrub it like you got a brand
new so it's all shiny yeah and then the
more you grill the more black stuff's on
there and then you start eating and you
realize there's no negative
repercussions so you pretty soon you
don't really give a [ __ ] this is why I
don't try
you just put food on it and you're like
why do I clean anything yeah you're
seeing better you're seasoning the pots
or season why people wipe your [ __ ]
their grill as other people gonna lick
it I wipe it but like also like when you
when you when you when the winners build
up on a girl I feel like it makes it
taste better than with the dishes now
she won't she won't deny the fact that I
get them really clean she's things I
haven't unnecessary like steps to when I
do it alright so let me tell you let me
show you how she does it okay okay she
does it okay so let's see we have the
two the double sinks sinks right yeah
white dragon yeah [ __ ] dish rack on
this side and there'll be the dirty
dishes here she lets them like soak a
little bit and then she'll grab each one
with the soapy sponge soap it up rinse
it off put it in a wrap yes good way to
do it
soap it up rinse it off in the back all
right here's what I do okay I feel like
it's a more streamlined process so I
have my dirty dishes here I take my
[ __ ] rack out all right mm-hmm
where do you put it um so I take my
[ __ ] spray water I rinse off every
dish first like a pre rinse to get all
the excess food off then I put on this
side when I have my pile of pre rinse
dishes I soap every single one back to
this side so I have a pile of soaked up
dishes sponges up dishes and then I go
rinse them back over here put it in the
right yeah that makes sense she is right
okay soak in them like then you don't
have to rinse each one pre rinse each
one you can soak them first and then
also like you love all the all the
dishes with the soap on it like the soap
starts drying on the first dish you did
and then a new wrist it's not as
thorough of a wrist nah man you just
they're all [ __ ] they're chilling you
just let you in the door
but you always the dishwasher this was
before we start using the dishwasher
because that's a live say yeah yeah you
just have to rinse but here's the thing
pants though sometimes go you got the
food things that are stuck on the plate
you gotta scrub those on yeah clog your
dishwasher if you've been letting it sit
there for a while you might have to but
then also another way to do it so people
like to that in the beginning sometimes
I might [ __ ] it I just throw it in the
dishwasher then when I take it out I'm
like oh this one has extra attention
everything else looks good alright
here's another method alright guys get
the hot hottest water you can and as
soon as you're done with the dishes
eating it blast it real quick and throw
it into the dishwasher and let that pile
up no I definitely do that yeah that's
our problem by the best one we both
leave our plates out after we eat and
then we take it into the kitchen I got a
so good yeah you get food coma you're
just like you're done eating oh yeah
let's go watch TV
yeah I got a bug I need to kind of rinse
my dishes right away even if we're in
the middle I'll be like yellow pause the
show I'm just gonna that's good you know
what I started do I started cleaning
right after eating now because that is
actually the cure to food coma is
movement mmm so like I started realizing
this in the foreign lands of Europe I
wasn't getting food coma because you
walk so much you eat and then you just
start walking mm-hm so I'm like alright
so I have a routine now I eat I rinse I
walk around the block really after you
after your meals at home thank you and
that old man
that's what she left right no and I
don't get food coma anymore while we
also eat a lot of food yeah you probably
eat like a good amount well my appetites
changed y'all still like going on food
like that like you do you eat till
you're full full cuz like I I kind of I
don't do that anymore are you - look
who's done saying yeah yeah I portion it
out so like what you're supposed to eat
and then I I think my body's just been
doing that so long it's trained to just
eat that portion size thanks and I
always have leftovers you don't eat and
go
I need another pecker mr. noodles
healthy food and I'm like there's
something missing yo and then I need
like a bowl of rice or something I don't
remember
okay not rice is fine yeah just
something else you know like yeah
whenever I like [ __ ] eat like a
really healthy dinner like a black salad
it's like mainly proteins and not too
many like you know carbs and [ __ ] I'm
like ma'am I feel so healthy right now
but I'm [ __ ] fiber I was gonna be
eating like ice cream or chips like an
elevator
are you are you guys all cooking more
now or are you guys post-meeting more
and stuff now I started post me again
like way more how come just as easier
Angelina it's funny cuz you actually
cook the most out of all of us during
pre quarantine I was cooking a lot and
it was like you get tired yeah cuz now
it's for me I was cooking for my
roommates but then when I'm just like
eating alone it also makes feast
- that's trauma time plus if you're
cooking for like one or two people it's
a [ __ ] that you know yet all those
[ __ ] pots and [ __ ] yeah that's why I
like a bulk cooking like pastas lasagnas
[ __ ] it like you can last for like three
days your stockpot types yeah yes stews
do you guys eat dinner leftovers for
breakfast yeah I eat anything for
anything same dog I love that what I do
to make it a breakfast is I just put a
fried egg on top of anything and I'm
like that's [ __ ] breakfast right same
I saw a pizza
yeah well what I like to do is like when
there's leftover spaghetti while I'm
warming up in like a
and then I'll throw an egg in there
[ __ ] scramble the egg in there okay
all breakfast spaghetti you know what I
like about this quarantine those I feel
like well he's for me there's zero food
waste I'm eating everything yeah
nothing produce my badge yeah it's crazy
that's the only thing that goes bad for
me is fruits but chips don't go bad you
buy fruits and it just sits there and it
rots the other day he was eating chips
was like yo these expired like five
months ago oh my god good eat it no
matter what yo you ever seen you ever
like go through your condiments and your
fridge and they actually have expiration
dates [ __ ] it's bad bad I catch up
changes color ketchup turns darker and
darker though it was a bottle of Tapatio
in here like a year ago that I was like
it's you know it's your man I think it
was supposed to be green right I
remember being like a little kid and
feeling like the mayonnaise and ketchup
was in my fridge for like years and just
not even carry inspire like how do you
tell if man is expired
read that label yeah but do you really
trust a date though cuz I've had eggs
way past a day and it's still good
oh that's just they have to do that for
like safety precautions oh best by dates
yeah it's like freshest by but it's like
it's not like you're gonna die okay
after cuz like milk you you you you're
supposed to be able to drink whenever
they just turn sour
Oh cuz all they kill all the germs
before they get it because we have
pasteurized eggs oh if you guys tried
ice cream after I got all the frozen
icicles on there and three years old
freezer tastes like your freezer yeah
still taste if you have there's like no
liquid left in there it's all like gummy
ice cream yeah frozen but sometimes just
gotta finish it
you don't go to waste you let it go two
ways you could let fruits go two ways
but not ice cream I see my mom gets
pissed cuz like you know we'll go get
dinner at their house every week and the
show is gives me [ __ ] like a huge bag
of oranges or
[ __ ] just like she gives us a lot of
food but then it's always like a huge
bag of guavas or some machine it's mad
because she's like you know then the
next week she's like did you finish that
bag of oranges like no mom it was like
so much but it's always I wasn't up with
like just that POW rotten fruit yeah
because it's it's too much it's just
ladder or make her happy
where does she get guavas I want some
quality that's expensive heard I would
be pissed if I gave you koalas we grow
some I think they go guavas in the
backyard the white ones are the pink
ones white ones oh yeah like the kind of
like light greenish white yeah yeah yeah
yeah entire so they're called phalanx I
think all their parents they eat fruits
like it's snacks yes we have like chips
cookies all kinds of stuff so we don't
eat as much fruit so I'm a fruit month
oh you're from my constant Oh especially
seasonal like it like cherries are in
season oh yeah [ __ ] love cherries and
then watermelons about to be in season
no you know I'm already started on
watermelon girl but why not the
supermarket I should try this right so
I'm like I'm trying to so this week I
start on my diet I got the quarantine 15
all right I bought south and I bought
protein and yeah I can really see it but
what I got chubbier yeah okay and then
sauce I got a fruits right so I get I
got cherry some strawberries and then a
watermelon it's cuz I'm gonna eat that
for a snack when you walk through the
ice-cream section and you see watermelon
slush and it's strawberry slush and
cherry slush like you know the Italian
ice thing oh yeah get those now and I
put the other fruits back I look at I'm
on my watermelon or a watermelon Italian
ice bottom in Italian you know that's
crazy cuz I see it as two different
things yeah and sometimes I just crave
fruit over the fake sugars I don't know
but when you get a really good fruit
though that [ __ ] is just as good as like
ice cream it so much better yeah
I am I bought these uh just got it you
just got to get the best ones cuz like
there's some oranges right now you eat
it you just like oh [ __ ] I'm glad I left
that in the fridge orange cream pops oh
you put it in the fridge yeah it's even
better good little tangerines in the
fridge Oh fire water I I bought some
cherries and then I like the white
cherries you guys have the white oh no I
haven't had those why cherries are like
[ __ ] next-level bro so anyways on my
mom's house and my mom had a but like
the UH
bowl of the regular red cherries and
she's like here have some cherries after
dinner I was like no I got cherries at
home she goes these are better Wow what
are they better person she is no they
were not white cherries always a better
you haven't tried a what no I love a
white chair you know that existed like
albino cherries
there's all Rainiers is that what the
cherry isyes are made out of actually
white they almost look like like yellow
yea yellowish with hints of pinkish oh
that was okay I know what you're talking
about I have not tried to us very good
ok I leave reckon ok well I'll try them
now 10 out of 10 10 10 would be yeah
what's your favorite fruit probably
mango everyone angles good just [ __ ]
inhale raspberries like Steve buys and
I'm like that's good quick but they
don't have much flavor I feel like oh my
god you have not gotten good raspberries
their blackberries over raspberry
blackberries oh you are in a different
category with you on has berries right
now you said raspberries everyone's like
just is just tart Luciana raspberry you
know and you know why we have
raspberries cos [ __ ] she ordered
groceries online and the [ __ ] guy
brought us raspberries instead of
blackberries do you get Driscoll E I get
a little Colby sometime
no it's got the it's well there are
different colors and they're got seeds
yeah it looks like little grapes
yeah and they like it's like have a
crunchy Center isn't expiration Bush oh
I see yeah raspberry I'm like where's
the seed in the middle it's just hot
that's why I'm super it's red I like
refrigerated peaches my favorite one ice
cream form well it's like I like the
cherries that come on top of the ice
cream and so Japan has like this like
luxury fruit like industry oh yeah it's
like $10 for a strawberry and it's it's
it's the it's the first time when I
realize that it's not all hype like when
you eat something and you're like ah
[ __ ] it's not really worth the price it
was worth the price it's like candy it's
a straight-up candy great you bet you
don't drink part because my favorite
thing to do is just to cut up a bunch of
watermelon put it in the freezer put
take the stems off the strawberries put
them in the freezer and then when I want
some like something refreshing I take
the frozen fruit put some vodka in there
maybe a little bit of lemonade blend it
after watching best cocktails after
watching the Irishmen I've always wanted
to cut the watermelon and stick the
photo stick with it I'm like [ __ ]
right I've done that but it's it doesn't
taste good
yeah what happens like so they soak the
watermelon with vodka yeah and so like
when you eat watermelon you get a hint
of vodka
oh you puree it yeah most people just
like less so good then you can slice it
in the watermelon yeah that way I was
seeing the keg mmm you know like it was
that what you're talking about
no I'm saying about this from the movie
oh you don't want it well you're not
missing much either that's my card
oh but you know in terms of [ __ ]
hyped up fruit I take back mangoes are
my [ __ ] and mangosteen looks like a
little [ __ ] brain and they're really
expensive to buy out here but in Vietnam
or Southeast Asia it's everywhere so
never tasted a fruit like this dog they
actually have it here now because they
ship it frozen but it's not that
expensive too expensive it's not the
same McGavin a it's like round like this
yeah tennis ball little Tomatoes and
it's got a hard [ __ ] shell it's it
looks like a cartoon almost yeah dark
purple almost black color yeah and on
the top it's got this green little like
you know like a like a like a hat like
yeah you gotta break it over your
partner yeah first time I had it was in
Malaysia and it blew my mind yeah oh my
valise roommate would give me something
yet in an inside it looks like a cuties
tangerine but it's all white yeah and
there's a seed in there yeah it's a
little seed it's the best thing ever
dude you're right I think that would be
my number one yeah yeah I was gonna say
that too also jackfruit if we're talking
about Southeast Asian for his beak
Jane's meet with but the [ __ ] in actual
fresh jackfruit it tastes like [ __ ]
candy I can do you have you ever tried
it
nah oh my god if you never tried wait
wait hey no wait you're yes I have oh
you know orange thing right yeah juicy
fruit gum was based off of Jack Jack
fruit because when I might taste it I
was like this unlocks something from my
childhood and I don't even understand
I've never seen this fruit of my life
and then yeah you eat it and you're like
juicy fruit gum
why do they use jackfruit for substitute
me because sure the texture yeah but
it's not good it's not the same as like
yes it is really I've had so many like
Jackson tacos and it was nothing
someone's made it for you really I had a
bomb jackfruit um nachos and I was like
this is fire Steve we refer Zee
they made that into fake me yeah like
you can eat just flavor it you have to
overnight marinate it and like flavor it
correctly but it takes on the flavor of
whatever you're putting in and it can't
be the fruit fruit that's too sweet it's
like young jackfruit where there's no
flavor at all yet yeah it was like
shredded chicken yeah it tastes better
than animals I mean I wouldn't say all
yeah but it's not like better it's it's
just lighter got all the flavor without
feeling heavier that's how I feel about
the tofu cheesecake yeah lighter that's
a whole food cheesecakes good they had
it at curry house by curry house close
down did you know about that did not oh
I did hear about that yes yes you had
the tofutti tofu ice cream sandwiches my
fave to foreign you could get it at
Trader Joe's and it feels like there's a
lot heavy hmm
yeah it's the best man oh dude I think
there's so much food to eat in the world
I don't eat at all we could you possibly
eat it all it's overwhelming so much I
think about it I'm like you know it's
like I just think in my mind is like
what's your first restaurant you guys
gonna go to after this great this way
are they open now no no some of them are
in the Oh season are open to go okay the
same home not in LA County but some
restaurants are opening to for dine in
County um and somehow patio is open Oh
like in Santa Barbara on State Street
like some of the restaurants have the
patio dining open
well like OC doesn't care they're just
opening so we should just go somewhere
that to eat we just I know it's very
confusing because I'm like wait or
quarantine well then we could go
somewhere to eat right because like half
of our gym stuff is going to the OC to
go workout regions are open already
there's driving there to go work out and
they come back and I see people will my
friend went to Georgia and he's doing
like airsoft games and he's like eating
at a restaurant and I'm all like they're
open yeah completely floored is the same
yeah my roommates in Florida and they're
just at bars and they posting like it
nothing ever happened oh no man Ford as
well what is crazy is I wouldn't take
something like from Florida and be like
yes and do what they're doing
you're not gonna model your life after
Disneyland again Disney World the lands
better okay so sorry sir Sir its new
that's better
open nope okay hey it's motto our lives
after Disneyland they're not open yeah
we'll open with Disney opens I'm down
you know Disney really saw their like
recipes I think I talked about this but
yeah sure all that yeah i actually
searched it up after you said that yeah
can you make you with the household
equipment like charles yeah i mean like
it's deep-fried but so you have to deep
fry it but other than that yeah it's
like eggs and nature but sure oh the
shape there's like the little um little
nozzle start the nozzle that like how
you make frosting oh you played out
thank you Dad or you could just I don't
know if you want the perfect shape just
get a ziploc bag and cut the corner
Audrey that's how you bake a baby I just
buy Charles
[Music]